E
DROP POD HERE.
THIS WILL HELP US GET DOWN TO
PROMETHEA, IN FACT, WHY NOT SKIP
AHEAD A LITTLE BIT.
RATHER THAN START AT THE
BEGINNING OF PROMETHEA, WE CAN
JUMP FORWARD, A BUNCH OF LEVELS
AND I WANT TO SHOW YOU EXCITING
ACTION HERE.
IN THIS, PROMETHEA IS THE ATLAS
OF THE CORPORATION.
YOU WILL NOTICE THAT ATLAS IS
UNDER SIEGE BY MALLAWAN AND
PRIVATE ARMY.
IN BORDERLANDS, IN THIS
UNIVERSE, WHEN A CORPORATION
ATTEMPTS A HOSTILE TAKEOVER,
THEY DO IT WITH FULL MILITARY
GRADES FOR.
>> NOW BEFORE WE START, I WANT
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE GUN WE
ARE USING HERE.
THIS IS AN ATLAS PISTOL.
NOW THE COOL THING ABOUT AN
ATLAS PISTOL IS THAT IT HAS ALT
FIRE MODE THAT FIRES OUT A
TRACKING DART.
WHEN YOU FIRE THE TRACKING DART,
IT MARKS THE TARGET.
EVERY BULLET YOU FIRE
SUBSEQUENTLY WILL HIT THAT
TARGET.
LIKE THE FIFTH ELEMENT GUN.
>> FINALLY.
[APPLAUSE] SO LET ME INTRODUCE
OUR DEMOS, WE HAVE CHRIS PLAYING
AS ZANE.
ZANE IS CO-OP BUDDY THIS TIME.
PAUL IS PLAYING AS AMARA WHICH
IS WHAT IS ON SCREEN FOR US TO
WATCH.
YOU NOTICE AMARA AND ZANE ARE AT
LEVEL 10.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY SET THEM UP
WITH MICROPHONES SO THAT WE CAN
LISTEN IN ON CHATTER AS THEY
PLAY.
PAUL, CHRIS, YOU GUYS READY?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> HEY!
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S WATCH.
THIS IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
BORDERLANDS 3 CO-OP LIVE STREAM.
TAKE IT AWAY, PAUL AND CHRIS.
>> AFTER YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING IN.
A BUNCH OF ENEMIES OVER HERE.
I WILL HEAD ON THE RIGHT SIDE
AND TRY TO SPLIT THEM UP.
I SEE A COUPLE BEHIND THEM.
POP A TRACKER.
>> SWITCHING OVER.
>> NICE SHOT.
>> TAKING OFF SHIELD.
SWITCHING TO FIRE.
GROUND PLAN.
>> YES.
>> ONE ON THE LEFT.
WAR PACKER IS IN.
GRENADES ON THE CROWD, RAIN.
>> UP AND OVER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND YOU HAVE ONE THERE.
>> CAN YOU --
>> MISS MY DOOR.
HIT THEM WITH A GRENADE.
HE'S DOWN.
>> NICE.
>> THAT WEAPON DEPOT ISS A JUICY
TARGET.
THEY HAVE FORCE FIELD AROUND IT.
IF YOU SOMEHOW CRACK IT OPEN,
YOU WILL FIND SOME QUALITY FIRE
POWER IN THERE.
>> SO YOU HAVE JUST HEARD FROM
AURELIA.
WE PASSED HER INTRODUCTION AND
SKIPPED AHEAD.
TRUST YOU WILL BE ABLE TO MEET
AND SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH
AURELIA.
AS YOU EXPLORE PROMETHEA AND
OTHER AREAS IN BORDERLANDS 3.
AND YOU READY TO FINISH THE
FIGHT?
>> LET'S GO.
DO IT.
>> I'M GOING AROUND RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THROWING DOWN THE SHIELD.
>> COOL.
GOING TO SWING INTO THE SHIELD.
TAKING OUT SHIELD FOR YOU.
>> YEAH.
PICKING IT UP.
>> SWITCHING.
>> TRACKING.
>> PULL THEM ALL IN.
NICE.
WE HAVE A BIG CROWD ON THE LEFT
HERE.
>> SWITCH TO SHOTGUN.
>> FLASH SHOOTER.
GO FOR THE PACK.
>> I HAVE THIS GUY.
>> WE HAVE TWO MORE OVER THERE.
NICE.
LAST ONE.
HE'S DONE.
>> NICE.
>> A CHEST BACK HERE.
>> SEE WHAT YOU GET.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GOT A LEAD OFF PISTOLS.
>> IT IS LITTLE OP.
BUT YOU GUYS CAN SAVE IT.
>> DELAYED FIRE MODE.
THAT IS COOL.
>> READY TO MOVE ON?
>> ALL RIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WOW!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] THANK YOU